está la estación este de budapest la
capital de hungría y hasta aquí llegan
cada media hora tienes que provienen de
la flor
los animales
pero también hemos visto muchísimos
extranjeros
estudiantes que vivían en ucrania
a algunos latinoamericanos y aquí un
poco más adelante un gran centro de
acogida aquí muchas cosas ha apuntado su
donde para recibir a estas personas que
llegan también hay hoteles que han
destinado algunas habitaciones hay
iglesias y éste termina siendo un lugar
de paz son muchos de ellos siguen luego
hacia otras ciudades europeas hace poco
hablábamos con kate de 31 años que es
una científica especializada en
información y nos decía que iba con su
hijo de 5 años porque ya no resistía más
las bombas en pie iban camino austrias y
miles y miles de personas me pasan por
estas canciones